welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
We got another look at Jessica Jones
with Daredevil and Kingpin this week.
So I'll explain what's going on with them
bringing her back to the MCU Daredevil
Born Again Episodes and the other Netflix
defenders characters
like The Punisher, who's
also going to have a huge story arc
during the new episodes.
of course I'll be doing
episode videos for it when it premieres.
Be sure to subscribe to get all those.
there'll be a lot more stuff
happening later this year
and early next year
just because everything is paused
right now with the strikes.
They've been delayed just a little bit,
would they might wind up doing
now is premiering
the first half of the show
in summer next year.
And then the second half of the show
at the beginning of 2025.
So for the most part,
if you've heard about things
getting delayed, movies, TV
shows, the Marvel stuff,
most of it has been delayed
by a couple of months.
Not everything, but some stuff
don't worry about it right now.
We'll just get to see
all that stuff eventually.
And I'll talk about the other movies
and shows when I do videos.
For those specifically,
starting with all the new Jessica
Jones stuff, though
this is on top of Easter eggs everyone
spotted in real life earlier this year.
But this past week, Vincent D'Onofrio,
Charlie Cox and Krysten
Ritter were at a convention together
going full defenders.
That's
why they were posting all these pictures,
even though technically Vincent
D'Onofrio Kingpin
didn't appear
in the actual Netflix Defenders series,
which seems like an oversight, like it
feels like he should have been in that.
right now, as I'm posting this video,
the show has been on break
recently for the strikes, but the actors
can still do stuff like this together.
That's why you're seeing them
post these pictures together
when all the shows were still on the air
back in the day on Netflix,
they didn't actually do that
many conventions together.
But since they got canceled, like
Daredevil, Jessica Jones, all the other
shows getting canceled, They started doing
way, way more conventions.
Then obviously, we saw them
come back during Spider-Man,
no way home in the Hawkeye series.
And it was just confirmed
a lot of our suspicions.
a lot of people then assumed that we would
eventually see Krysten Ritter come back
as Jessica Jones, because earlier
this year she was spotted in Real life
teasing her return.
can see her wearing a bit of a born again
T-shirt here.
The logo is the exact same
as the new MCU version, the logo
that Kevin Vickie just debuted at D23.
The big Daredevil panel.
Aren't you supposed to talk about my show
with your show?
I think you mean my show.
You're not going to
tell me. Resistant to.
the funny thing about that is
they were both there for the Echo panel,
for the Echo episodes,
and they just stayed for the Daredevil
Born Again episodes all explained
what's happening during Echo
soon to because there's a big Daredevil
kingpin storyline during that.
but they were just joking about whose show
daredevil Born Again would be like
Daredevil is in the title
You think it's about him.
So Charlie Cox is like,
What are you talking about? My show?
But obviously Vincent D'Onofrio
just joking.
The kingpin is going to believe
that it's true.
It's all about him.
the reason why we were probably seeing
Krysten Ritter posting
this daredevil related stuff was because
at the time that she posted it,
they were getting ready to actually start
filming Daredevil Born Again episodes.
with all the delays.
There's still a lot of filming left to do.
So they obviously delayed
the premiere dates
and it was originally supposed to premiere
after the Echo episodes,
which they just delayed
to the beginning of 2024.
so regardless
of how long all these delays last, it's
still coming after the Echo episodes.
according to reports,
Marvel also had a plan to bring Krysten
Ritter back as Jessica Jones
before this during the She-Hulk
episodes, Which makes sense
because her day job is a paralegal.
So you'd expect her Jennifer Walters,
Matt Murdock, to cross paths
in the normal course of their jobs
outside of being vigilantes.
it was a whole basis for Daredevil's
cameo on She-Hulk.
He was in L.A. as Matt Murdock,
first as a lawyer.
They had a teaser while he was there
for his new daredevil suits as well too.
Like, it turns out that he's getting his
new suits from this person in L.A. Now
the new suits that he references,
there are suits
that he'll wear in the future.
On the Echo series and Daredevil
Born Again, Like
there are a couple of other suits
that were made for him that we didn't see
because we won't see them
until Echo and Daredevil born again.
all the new ones are meant to be versions
of his comic book suits,
like the yellow one was based on his
very first red and yellow suit
from his first comics appearance.
that was why they had
all the jokes about it on the series
about looking like ketchup and mustard.
Like,
why would you wear such clashing colors?
Like, wouldn't
you want to not stand out in the battle?
he was wearing it
because it was his first comic book suit.
And obviously, like a lot of the logic
in those classic comics is really jokey.
he'll
also have a version of his classic
red suit rematch
and like a brand new version
of the red suit,
not the same one
that he wore during Daredevil.
Netflix, he'll also have a version
of his newer black suit,
not the classic one from the Daredevil
Netflix series like the low fi black suit.
the new one, would be like the back
in black costume,
which is just a little bit different,
like an upgraded black costume.
the story for Jessica Jones in the MCU
probably hasn't changed that much,
even though
they've moved around some of the series.
And they got rid of her
cameo scenes during She-Hulk.
but during the Echo episodes are supposed
to be a bunch of daredevil and kingpin
because of Kingpin's relationship
with Echo, he's
meant to be one of the main
villains of that series too,
but in a much bigger way
than he was during the Hawkeye series.
Like during Hawkeye,
it was a pretty short cameo
any of though there was a little bit
more of Daredevil
during the She-Hulk episodes,
that was still just a smaller cameo.
They're supposed to be more of them,
more scenes for them in the Echo series.
and it'll be the first time that Daredevil
and Kingpin are in the same series,
like in the same production
together in the MCU.
Even though canonically they're
treating the characters
almost as the same versions
in the Netflix series.
They're picking and choosing
what parts of the canon
they bring forward
from the Netflix series.
But for the most part,
the series is supposed to be canon,
But according to Charlie Cox, the
reimagining some aspects from the show,
like not every single little thing
is going to be something that they carry
forward, really good example.
That's why the yellow suit on She-Hulk
looked almost exactly the same
as the classic
red suit on the Netflix series.
Just to show you
that most of that stuff was Canon.
during the Echo
episodes, the story for Jessica Jones
is supposed to be that she's missing in
Daredevil is looking for her.
Aside from the main story of Echo versus
kingpin and Daredevil versus kingpin
going on.
so while they're all busy
in the background,
Daredevil is still looking for
Jessica Jones
the whole idea with Kingpin is that Echo
didn't kill him at the end of Hawkeye.
They just made it seem that way.
This ending scene
is just right out of the comics.
Her back story on the series
is similar to the comics version.
She's from the Daredevil comics.
Like a lot of the She-Hulk villains,
most of the smaller,
funny villains were either like
Daredevil villains or Punisher villains,
because they're bringing
so many of the Netflix characters
into the MCU in a much more proper way.
Kingpin raised Echo to be his weapon,
lied to her, saying
that Daredevil killed her father
so that she'd be more effective
in trying to get rid of him for Kingpin,
then secretly, as we saw in Hawkeye,
it was Kingpin who killed her
father, betraying her.
so they just did a version of that
on the Hawkeye series.
she suits him in revenge the same way,
but only winds up blinding him.
And when he returns, it's
meant to be this ironic twist
because he's blind,
just like Daredevil for a little while.
But eventually he gets his sight back.
the whole thing with the Echo series
is supposed to explore some special powers
in mythology that they teased during her
bedtime story with their father.
Like they talk about this crazy magic,
the story that he tells her supposedly
that's going to turn into
like a real thing during the Echo
series, it, it'll be that stuff
lead with regular crime thriller
because you have daredevil
kingpin characters
Jessica Jones
might have a cameo scene in Echo.
I don't think she's supposed to,
but it's always possible that they change
some of that because they shuffle
the series around a little bit.
There've been a couple of delays,
he is supposed to find her
during Daredevil born again.
And she's a bigger part of the plot
during that series
like the way that you would expect her
when they say
that she's going to be
a big part of the series
the way that Charlie Cox
talked about the episodes.
He said that Daredevil Born Again
would be just like the tone
and the vibe of the Netflix series.
But because they had so many extra
episodes,
they'd be doing way more courtroom scenes
like you saw during Daredevil Season two
when he was defending The Punisher,
there's been a bunch of footage of Jon
Bernthal just working out on Daredevil,
Born Again, just in general.
The other Netflix defenders character said
that they love to come back.
It's just a question of availability and
what room they have for them in the story.
Like what are they already doing?
like Luke Cage, Colleen Wing, even Finn
Jones said that
he wanted to come back as Iron Fist.
You probably saw that recently too.
Some news articles about Iron Fist
wanting to prove people wrong
that he would come back in the MCU.
We'll see about that.
I really wasn't a fan of what they did
with the character.
So I'm totally fine with them
just waiting to use him for years
or just completely recasting the iron Fist
role in the MCU.
my actual MCU iron fist idea is for them
to just do something
completely separate with him and use him
as one of the villains of the Sheng
Xi series
because he's supposed to be a hero.
but because Shang.
She's people worship
the great protector dragon and Tall Low in
Iron Fist gets his powers
from killing a cosmic dragon.
They should just say that MCU Iron Fist
winds up killing the Great Protector.
Dragon is part of his origin story.
instead at the concept of the capital.
Cities of heaven can learn their celestial
configuration, the Tournament of Heaven,
and you that they exist
in the same alternate dimension.
The tall low does And they can use
the iron fist mythology in the Tournament
of Heaven to do a really bad as Shang
Xi Tournament arc for the character.
like classic Bruce Lee Enter the Dragon,
which they kind of use as inspiration
for some of the first Shang Xi movie.
like we all want to see Shang.
She get a much cooler tournament arc,
the Iron Fist Tournament of Heaven
in the capital cities of Heaven
would be the way to do that.
then they can just fold iron fist
into more ground level,
daredevil street level stuff in the MCU.
the bigger storyline
they're supposed to be doing
during Daredevil, Born again in season
one is Mega Kingpin like the whole idea
in Marvel Phase five just in general,
all the movies, all the series is
they're going with a very dark rain
inspired, overarching story
spinning out of secret invasion,
where the antagonists take control
and positions of power.
Thunderbolt Ross is supposed to become
president of the United States around
the same time, like in Captain America,
four New World Order,
which is being released
right around the same time
the date of a born again
is being released.
Val has already become director
of the CIA, now wielding enormous power,
which she's going to use
to create the Thunderbolts.
And it all spins out of what happens
with the evil scrolls and secret invasion
in the whole idea
is that the villains, the antagonists,
start
taking credit for getting rid of them.
in writing that wave of popularity
to even greater political power,
kingpin's story is just localized
to New York City, with him
basically taking control of New York City,
riding that wave
and turning it into something more
akin to a police state, like doing
really terrible stuff in the light of day
and people loving him for it
because of what happened with
the scroll is like,
look, see if we're not this hard core in
the skrulls
are going to take over the planet again.
but. Everyone let me know in the comments.
What do you want them to do with the other
Netflix defenders characters?
It sounds like we'll see them in addition
to Jessica Jones in the next few years.
We'll start getting some more data
of a born again footage
when they start actually
filming the episodes again.
So, of course, I'll do more videos
once that happens.
And my Ahsoka episode
for video will post next.
So be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
everyone click here for that video.
Update the link as soon as I post
that and click here to learn
what's going on with the Doctor
Strange 3 movie.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!